so when another one of your wonderful
keynote speeches i believe it was 2010
it was in berkeley committee on speech
you said that both your parents love
their work yeah and they instill in you
a belief that you should strive for the
same yeah so knowing that your mom and
you have two beautiful daughters what
would you say to them if they come to
you and say mom I want to make my living
in the creative arts would you say take
a double major take the dance but also
do the business I would say also do the
business I wouldn't deter them at all
but I think so many artists and
filmmakers do not spend enough time
understanding how to run a business and
how to be business people and right
investor reports and future planning and
that's the pricey they feed each other
like I'm able to make all these films I
run a film studio I have you know five
people that full time and I don't do any
of these things about myself I have a
great team that I've had for years
because I know how to do the business
side too and so to me I wish that every
art school every film school had a whole
track that you had to take which was
business classes when I really got my
ropes in business by running the webby
awards because I was at a very
conservative corporation ordered these
intense quarterly reports these
stressful board meetings this reporting
I would have to do was so stressful but
I learned how to i learned business from
all these Harvard Business School
executives and then I went and took a
Harvard executive education course and
which everyone can just take business
courses just because you didn't study at
school doesn't mean that you can't take
an evening business course but I just
breaks my heart to so many talented
filmmakers they just don't understand
business or they don't know how to ask
for money or they don't know how to
provide benefits for that money and
investment report there's so many things
that are critical to surviving as a
filmmaker I'm not just surviving but
flourishing that I just wish people took
the business side more seriously in a
lot hours but all I am it's not a
business person well you're never you
need you need to
think of that as just as important
because even so you don't get screwed in
business deals if you delegate that to
other people because you know a lot of
people don't how to read a contract and
they give away rights they shouldn't
give and there's good so I just feel
like I wish that was me I mean I wish
they'd talk business courses in high
school I would say that the majority of
all of our you know people not saving
enough credit card problems in our
country is because it's you know home at
which of course was shunned by the
feminist movement which I'm a FEMINIST
but homak was a lot about running a home
business and they took that class away
and and more people need to understand
business sure
you